Навпроти мене Каха Каладзе, мер Тбілісі і колишній професійний футболіст.
14 червня в Росії відкривається чемпіонат світу з футболу.
Це перший такий спортивний захід на пострадянському просторі.
Чи плануєте Ви відвідати якісь ігри?
Чесно кажучи, у мене не вийде приїхати, тому що
дуже багато роботи в Тбілісі, особливо в літній період.
Коли добра погода, треба максимально використовувати цей час,
аби в місті робити різні інфраструктурні проекти.
Тому доведеться дивитися чемпіонат світу по телевізору.
Є така точка зору, що великі спортивні заходи не повинні проводитися
в авторитарних або напівавторитарних країнах.
Як Ви ставитеся до критики того, що чемпіонат світу з футболу буде проходити в Росії?
Не знаю, чесно кажучи, якщо суто по-спортивному - побачимо.
Бо що найголовніше? Найголовніше - щоб була інфраструктура.
Щоб стадіони побудували нові, футбольні майданчики тощо.
Ще найголовніше, щоб усе було спокійно, щоб ніякого теракту і так далі.
Безпека - це дуже важливо.
Якщо політично дивитися, різні люди по-різному ставляться до цього,
по-різному оцінюють, що чемпіонат проходить у Росії.
Що стосується моєї думки - не знаю, просто важко мені обговорювати це, якщо чесно.
Найголовніше - щоб все пройшло спокійно.
Найголовніше - щоб все було на рівні, як і повинні
проводитися чемпіонати світу, чемпіонати Європи.
Збірна якої країни, на вашу думку, стане фаворитом на майбутньому чемпіонаті світу?
є сильні команди, як Бразилія, як німці, у них дуже
сильна команда, молодь дуже добра.
На жаль, італійці не потрапили на чемпіонат світу.
Дивно було для всіх уболівальників футболу.
Але у футболі все буває.
Футбольні клуби купують досить заможні люди, далекі від футболу.
Найголовніший приклад, якщо говорити про російський капітал,
- це, звичайно, Роман Абрамович, який володіє "Челсі".
Це шкідливо чи корисно для команд?
Якщо було б шкідливо, вони б не взяли такі команди
як, приміром, ось це добрий приклад: Роман Абрамович,
який взяв цю команду і, можна сказати, що "Челсі"
вважається однією з кращих команд на сьогодні.
У них фінансове становище дуже добре. Хороші футболісти грають.
Чемпіонат Англії - один з кращих чемпіонатів, можна сказати.
Навіть ті люди, які ніколи раніше футбол не дивилися,
коли починають вже всередині дивитися, як це все відбувається,
стають найсильнішими вболівальниками.
Пан Каладзе, ви в 2012 році почали свою політичну кар'єру,
ставши міністром енергетики Грузії.
Чому ви вирішили так різко поміняти фокус?
Чесно кажучи, я дуже багато думав до того,
як ухвалював це рішення, тому що, чесно кажучи, було нелегко.
Все життя грав у футбол, все життя віддав спорту.
І в один прекрасний день ухвалив зовсім інше рішення, яке...
А яке?
Змінити все моє життя. Чесно кажучи, це рішення було ухвалене
через те, що відбувалося в моїй країні.
Насправді була дуже складна ситуація.
Ви маєте на увазі 2012 рік?
12-й, так.
А у чому полягала ця складна ситуація?
Ну, я зараз просто не хочу багато говорити про це.
Я думаю, що всі все знають, яка була ситуація в країні.
Я ось одне скажу коротко, і всі все зрозуміють.
У нас ось, наприклад, була влада Саакашвілі, так?
Якщо звичайні люди, нормальні люди не думали так, як думає влада,
відразу б у владі говорили, що ти - ворог країни.
Тобто це був авторитарний режим іншими словами?
Можна і так сказати. Це була серйозна проблема для мене,
для звичайних людей, для всіх. І в один прекрасний день
це був 2011 рік, коли дуже багато було нігілізму у країні,
і ніхто не думав, ніхто не очікував, що щось зміниться. Тому що
опозиція була дуже слабка, і Саакашвілі говорив: все гарантовано.
І в один прекрасний день пан Іванішвілі зробив заяву, що він
не може терпіти те, що відбувається в країні, і що він іде в політику.
Всі люди, які вболівали за країну, переживали за те, що в країні відбувається,
всі стали довкола нього, об'єдналися.
У виборах, як у нормальних європейських країнах відбувається,
через вибори ми виграли в 2012 році.
Тобто не зовсім авторитарний режим, адже в Росії
не можна виграти вибори опозиції.
У Росії, чесно кажучи, немає лідерів, які б могли об'єднати народ.
Ви кажете, що в цій авторитарній або напівавторитарної країні
лідером опозиції має стати впливова фігура,
яка володіє великим капіталом. Чи не вважаєте Ви,
що все-таки існує конфлікт інтересів, коли людина, яка володіє величезними грошима
а Бідзіна Іванішвілі, я думаю, найбагатша людина в Грузії
при цьому має гігантський політичний вплив.
Це добре чи погано?
Я думаю, це дуже добре. Це навпаки допомагає йому.
Тому що, я знаю дуже багато випадків, коли люди
приходили у владу без нічого.   І потім багатими йшли.
Ми знаємо цей приклад, можу його навести.
Наведіть.
Наприклад, ось у владі Саакашвілі було дуже багато людей,
які вкрали там дуже багато грошей і втекли.
І нині їх шукає Інтерпол, місцева поліція і так далі.
Якщо ти совісна людина - як можна заробляти гроші в політиці?
Навпаки, ти в політиці для того, щоб допомогти країні.
Ти повинен робити ті реформи, які допоможуть
розвивати країну, розвивати демократію і так далі.
У цьому напрямку, чесно кажучи, ми дуже багато працювали.
Напевно, ми теж робимо помилки, але ми вчимося,
щоб іншим разом не повторилися помилки.
Ви не єдиний колишній професійний спортсмен,
який зайнявся політикою на пострадянському просторі.
найвідоміший, мабуть, це мер Києва Віталій Кличко, колишній боксер.
Величезна кількість спортсменів у російській Держдумі.
Щоправда, є сумніви, чи виграли вони на чесних виборах чи ні.
Чому є така тенденція в країнах пострадянського простору?
Не знаю. Важко мені відповісти.
Я коли ухвалював це рішення, я вам поясню, чому я ухвалив це рішення.
Мені нелегко було, тому що грав усе життя в футбол.
Я радився із сім'єю, з дружиною, тому що я жив тоді в Італії, в Мілані.
А Ви з Берлусконі радилися, до речі?
Ні, не радився. Берлусконі мене привітав, коли виграв вибори.
Якраз у жовтні він мені дзвонив, вітав.
Пане Каладзе, я зараз буду ставити вам бліц-запитання,
підглядаючи іноді в Айпад, бо я не дуже добре розбираюся
у футболі, а деякі запитання з цим пов'язані.
Отже: Рональду чи Мессі?
Який Рональду? Кріштіану чи...
Ну .. Я думаю, Кріштіану.
Касільяс чи Буффон?
Буффон.
Мальдіні чи Каладзе?
Мальдіні.
Берлусконі чи Іванішвілі?
Важко сказати, тому що один був у футболі
і в політиці, тричі був прем'єр-міністром Італії.
Пан Іванішвілі, я думаю, тому що він взяв
відповідальність тоді, коли було дуже важко грузинам і країні.
Піца чи хачапурі?
Хачапурі.
Пане Каладзе, спасибі Вам велике.
Дякую.